Well, these negative charges all want to get as close to the positive charges they possibly can--
which means all packing in to this one tiny little tip, which means the concentration will be higher.
This will turn out to be very important when we design a tool to save our buildings
from lightning strikes, and this is something that some people call the effect of points,
mainly that pointed objects tend to have higher concentrations of negative charge
accumulating in them in these situations than rounder objects or flat objects,
but there's still huge question to be answered--namely, where did this guy come from,
how do we get a positively charge object to begin with.
Far all we've seen are how an object can become polarized, how the charges can separate.
I want to know how to get a charge object.